oh not all the Gold's coming out of day
23 notes like d23 was like alright peace
you'll get a Star Wars trailer on Monday
Netflix's over there like we're all
talking about that now I don't know if
everyone is how much is it's gonna take
the internet by storm is they're gonna
take the internet by storm I'm I want to
talk about it which for a Breaking Bad
movie all I knew about the Breaking Bad
movies that oh yeah there were whispers
of a Breaking Bad movie okay if the
mandalorian video I did has taught you
anything please have your takeaway be I
don't have my finger on the pulse of my
ear to the ground of production I like
going into these things blind that's how
I get the most enjoyment out of it so
when I about things like maybe the
mandalorian is he Bubba fed it's coming
from a place of fan theory it's just how
I do it I heard whispers about a
Breaking Bad movie and I was like okay
maybe if they pull it off maybe which El
Camino means the way I did research that
one myself
but this trailer I've really liked the
trailer because first of all it's not
like Bryan Cranston popped out of
nowhere I was like where's Jesse so I
mean first of all that's great I don't
want Bryan Cranston in it well I don't
Walter White in it I can see a dream
sequence or something maybe but they
have to handle that really well but when
the first is zooming in to this office
you see the pictures of Hank Schrader
and Steve Gomez on the wall I was gonna
actually have that in the thumbnail with
a big circle around it it says 75
thousand things you idiots missed in
this trailer cuz those videos what
there's one already right there's one
out there you hear skinny Pete talking
and it didn't dawn on me until now how
much skinny Pete reminds me of Walton
Goggins but he does because I was like
is that Goggins oh no skinny Pete I
don't I was like I've been watching
hateful eight extended edition but I
mean skinny Pete's obviously getting
grilled and he brings up some really
fair and good points maybe I'm a little
biased because I like Jesse Pinkman I
mean Jesse Pinkman in the end that you
know murder Gale and cooked and peddled
meth you know but no skinny Pete's like
no I've seen the news footage I've seen
the cage they kept him in I'm not gonna
help you put Jesse Pinkman in another
cage it looks like it's the manhunt for
Jesse Pinkman which would happen it just
logistically it logically makes sense
not like they'd be like well pinkman's
gone the story is over
like I like the concept that Pinkman
just went away I know there's a whole
thing like he got Brock and he took him
to Alaska
it's like he kidnapped a child and took
him to Alaska that's not good or who
knows maybe he did maybe people did just
pick up Brock and they're like we need
to hunt for this person who kidnapped a
kid but I always thought like Pinkman
probably went to Alaska but the manhunt
wouldn't stop they did go after him but
I see skinny Pete side of it's like dude
can't you just can't you just say time
served yes sure and he killed a guy
cooked meth peddled meth did bad things
but he wasn't a bad guy can't we just
say time served he was tortured for
months and forced to cook meth that's
right I guess this is a Netflix movie
coming in November which everything is
coming out and like November it's like
October November from September through
November it's like the onslaught of
video games and entertainment that I
have coming to meets I don't even have
to have to breathe but I like this
trailer and after this trailer I was
actually on board with a Breaking Bad
movie I hope they don't do something
stupid like Walter White comes in like I
did I'm alive I mean can they wrap it up
in a movie is it gonna feel fulfilling
we're used to Breaking Bad giving us
this you know it's a long game but I saw
the trailer for Breaking Bad's El Camino
have you seen it what did you think
about it are you on board with the
Breaking Bad movie or a movie that takes
place in the Breaking Bad universe or
it's really Jessie movie the Jessie
manhunt movie [ __ ] what if it's like
Jessie but the fugitive I just got
really on board with this like in that
one sentence fugitive is the greatest
manhunt movie of all time but have you
seen the trailer what do you think are
you on board whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]